I think it is you,
the women, who have had the most diabolical lies told to you.
Yes, women have been lied to,
but I do not think it's the way that this guy's talking about.
Women have been lied to
with the expectation that the division of labor
when it comes to raising children and a family will be equitable,
because they are also pulling in a paycheck as a working parent,
at least socially for the majority.
Societally, we've made just enough room to allow women to go to work
and then also come home and do all of the domestic labor,
all while making less sense on the dollar than their male counterparts.
And that's even less if you are a black woman or a woman of color.
But I digress.
I am a Liberal,
progressive homemaker,
housewife, homeschooler.
I cook from scratch,
I have a garden.
So I understand the value of the work that I do
and the fulfillment that I get from it.
But I also have a university degree.
And you know what nobody wants to fucking hear
when they're sitting there
celebrating the hard work and dedication of the past four years
in order to get a degree,
regardless of how they feel about getting married or having kids.
Maybe they want to.
Doesn't really matter in this context,
because that's not what they are sitting there for.
Cause I don't know anybody.
And granted I didn't go to a conservative private Catholic college.
That probably changes the thoughts of the demographic.
But I don't know anybody who's gonna sit there at their graduation
and be like, huh,
this was fun. This was a fun little pastime.
I can't wait to be a homemaker.
And I graduated with plenty of women who ended up being housewives.
But, you know,
when they were not thinking about that at their college graduation,
I know I wasn't.
Because my role as a homemaker
housewife did not come out of patriarchal or religious pressure.
It came out of financial reasons.
It came out of looking at our lifestyle,
looking at how much time I would wanna be around my own kids,
looking at the price of child care,
looking at the lifestyle that it would afford us.
You know, all sorts of, like,
other reasons that are completely valid.
But their graduation
speech is the moment you thought these young ladies
would want to hear,
like, a celebratory, good job, ladies.
But, like,
we all know you just wanna have kids.
That's a perfectly valid life choice, too.
You should do that.
Look how happy my wife is.
My wife, who's.
Who's the wife of an NFL, Super Bowl winning kicker.
Yeah. Being a housewife and a homemaker
under those circumstances
is probably gonna look a lot different than for a lot of other people.
I mean, I'm not really surprised.
Like, this was a commencement speech.
I know the entire thing is meant to, like,
Just incense the general public.
But like, this was a commencement speech to a very specific audience.
And that audience are people who are so aligned with Catholicism
and the Catholic faith
that they decided to go to a private Catholic University.
And these are the views of conservative Christianity.
And truly, if you wanna talk about it,
these are the views of a lot of religions.
The further into orthodoxy and conservatism you get.
Fun personal note.
My mom was actually raised Catholic, and, um,
she went to a Catholic university.
And she had such a horrible experience there, um,
that she met my dad right after graduation
and married him and converted to Judaism.
So good job with the PR.
Oh, she also went to a post grad and became a doctor. So go mom!